like so many of us i was told to know my
place
but here i am allison felix is breaking
records after winning her 10th medal at
the tokyo olympics
the 35 year old u.s track star took home
the bronze medal in the women's 400
meters on friday in a season best
49.46 seconds following that win
felix became the most decorated female
olympic track and field athlete in
history breaking a tie with jamaica's
marlene adi
who has nine medals she's also tied
legend carl lewis for the most medals by
an american track and field athlete
here i am using my voice to create
change
for us as women and for us as mothers
and for all the women who want to be
mothers felix began her olympic career
at age 18
and went on to win one medal in 2004
two in 2008 three in 2012
and three in 2016. the athlete then
qualified for her fifth olympics in june
when she finished second in the 400
meter event at the u.s
trial and her times gradually got better
in tokyo in the semi-finals she posted
49.89
seconds which was her first sub 50 run
since becoming a mom all of my
experience of becoming a mom
of raising a daughter helped show me my
true competitor
inequality this was felix's first
olympics since welcoming her daughter
in 2018 but not only is she a track star
and a mom she's also a businesswoman
felix won her bronze medal on friday
wearing racing spikes that she designed
for her new footwear line
seish the olympian launched the brand
which is also an apparel line
to quote disrupt traditional athletic
sponsorships
run in a brand that prioritizes black
maternal health
and provide more opportunities for women
within the footwear and sports
industries
here i am ready to run for a brand
that i founded designed for
and designed by women but before felix
gets back to business
she has a chance to break another
olympic record
the track star can beat carl lewis's
medal count when she competes in the
upcoming 4 by 400 relay race
over the weekend so here i am
i know my place